mr speaker i beg to move that this house
do not adjourn
the passing year of 72 hours has done
little to numb the shock and sadness we
all felt
when we heard of the tragic and
senseless death of sir david amos
this house
has lost a steadfast servant
we've lost a dear friend and colleague
and julia and her children
have lost a loving husband and devoted
father
nothing i
or anyone else can say will lessen the
pain
the grief
the anger
they must feel at this darkest of times
we hold them
in our hearts today
we mourn with them
and we grieve alongside them
sir david was taken from us in a
contemptible act of violence
striking at the core of what it is
to be a member of this house
and violating the sanctity both of the
church in which he was killed
and the constituency surgery that is so
essential to our representative
democracy
but we will not allow the manner of sir
david's death
in any way
to detract from his accomplishments as a
politician or as a human being
because david was a patriot who believed
passionately
in this country
in its people
in its future
he was also one of the nicest kindest
and most gentle individuals ever
to grace these benches
a man who used his decades of experience
to offer friendship and support to new
members of all parties
whose views often confounded expectation
and defied easy stereotype
and who believed not just in pointing
out what was wrong with society
but in getting on and doing something
about it
it was that determination
to make this country a better place
that inspired his outstanding record on
behalf
of the vulnerable and the voiceless
the master of the private member's bill
and 10-minute rule bill
he passed legislation on subjects as
diverse as animal welfare fuel poverty
and the registration of driving
instructors
he was a prodigious campaigner for
children with learning disabilities and
for women with endometriosis
a condition on which he became an expert
after meeting a woman
at one of his constituency surgeries
behind the famous and irresistible beam
lay a seasoned campaigner a verve and
grit
whether he was demanding freedom for the
people of iran
or courting votes in the westminster dog
of the year contest
whether he was battling for brexit or
fighting his way to the front of the
parliamentary pancake race
and as every member of this house will
known as you have just confirmed mr
speaker
he never once witnessed any achievement
by any resident of south end that could
not somehow be cited in his bid to
secure city status
for that distinguished time
[Applause]
highlights of that bulging folder
included a world record for playing
the most triangles at once
a group of stilt walkers traveling
non-stop from the essex coast to downey
street
and a visiting foreign dignitary
allegedly
flighting protocol by saying he liked
south end
more than cleethorpes
a compelling case uh mr speaker
and as it is only a short time
since sir david last put that very case
to me in this chamber
i am happy to announce
that her majesty has agreed
the south end
will be accorded the city status it so
clearly deserves
[Applause]
that's a david spent almost 40 years in
this house
but not one day in ministerial office
tells everything about where his
priorities lay
he was not a man in all of this chamber
nor a man who sought
patronage or advancement
he simply wanted to serve the people of
essex first in basildon then
in south end
and it was in the act of serving his
constituents that he was so cruelly
killed
in his recent memoir
sir david called surgeries
a part of the great british tradition
of the people openly meeting their
elected politicians
even after
the murder of joe cox and the savage
attacks on stephen timms and nigel jones
he refused to accept that he should be
in any way deterred from speaking face
to face with his constituents
and so when he died
he was doing what he firmly believed
was the most important part of any mp's
job
offering help
to those
in need
in the awful moments before we knew the
full horror of the tragedy
a member of sir david's constituency
association her voice breaking with
emotion
told an interviewer
that
we need him
the country
needs him
and we do
this country needs people like sir david
this house needs people like sir david
and our politics needs people like sir
david
dedicated passionate firm in his beliefs
but never anything less than respectful
for those who thought differently
those are the values he brought to a
lifetime of public service
there can be few among us more justified
than him
in his deep faith
in the resurrection
and the life to come
and while his death
leaves a vacuum
that will not
and can never be filled
we will
cherish
his memory
we will celebrate
his legacy
and we will never allow those who commit
acts of evil to triumph over the
democracy and the parliament that sir
david amos loved so much